good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is execute your idea over to you
jeff bezos so it's it's easy to have
ideas it's very hard to turn an idea
into a successful product there are a
lot of steps in between it takes
persistence relentlessness so I always
tell people who are you know who think
they want to be entrepreneurs it's you
need a combination of stubborn
relentlessness and flexibility and you
have to know when to bewitch and
basically you need to be stubborn on
your vision because otherwise it'll be
too easy to give up but you need to be
very flexible on the details because as
you go along pursuing your vision you'll
find that some of your preconceptions
were wrong you're gonna need to be able
to change those things so I think taking
an idea successfully all the way to the
market and turning it into a real
product that people care about and that
really improves people's lives it's a
lot of hard work I love this message
it's one of my favorite messages I
hundred percent agree with Jeff on this
one and I think you need to be insanely
stubborn about the mission insanely
stubborn about the why you're doing
things but really flexible about the how
and I think you need to have that
stubbornness especially as an
entrepreneur because when you're getting
started you're gonna get so much
pushback right what you create your
product your service won't be really
great at the start and so it'll be hard
to get people to buy from you you'll
have people around you friends family
co-workers you know people in your
community telling you that it's not
gonna work out you're telling yourself
that sometimes this is crazy and it's
not going to work out and so everything
around you is saying that this is crazy
and that maybe it's not the smartest
thing to do
I mean entrepreneur Israeli the smart
thing to do it might be the best thing
to do but what we do is we create a
world that does not exist like the best
entrepreneurs have a vision for a world
that they want to create that doesn't
exist yet so from a practical
perspective it doesn't make sense like
we're doing something that has never
been done before you guys need to be
doing something has never been done
before
right like you can model some success
but at some point you have to find your
own path and when you go and create your
own path it's not practical it's not
logical because it doesn't exist yet you
have to go and create it and so you need
to have that stubbornness for the
mission for the vision for what end
objective you're trying to create
because of all of the pushback and
negativity and zero progress you're
gonna make at the beginning if you don't
have that stubbornness if you aren't
willing to say no this is gonna work out
to yourself and to the people around you
who are naysayers then you're gonna quit
which most entrepreneurs end up doing
they they quit they don't have enough
stubbornness for where they want to go
the flexibility that was about how you
go and accomplish it I want to make this
world better here's how I want it to
look like here's here's what I want to
change in the industry but how you go
out and do it
should be flexible and this is where I
think too many entrepreneurs are too
stubborn it has to be this specific way
and this way only so you spend all this
time making this perfect plan right the
perfectionist you want to make this
perfect plan and you're all your time
was working on this plan this is exactly
how it's gonna play out no matter how
much planning you do it's never gonna go
according to that plan every successful
business look at how they started it's
not how they started that led them to
their ultimate success sometimes it's a
radical shift in their plan sometimes
it's a minor shift in their playing but
it always has to change just look at any
company look at how they started look at
Starbucks they started selling just
beans you couldn't get coffee going into
a Starbucks they would only sell you the
beans
BMW started selling airplanes that's why
their logo is an airplane propeller
you know Wrigley is the gun company
started selling other household products
and gum was just used as a as a giveaway
that if you buy x packs of this other
product will give you some gum
and the eventually became the gum
company rights like it changes so often
and too many entrees are stuck on that
has to be this specific way and if
you're not listening to the market if
you're not combining what you love with
what the market wants you're never going
to get to the success that you're after
and so that insane stubbornness for the
vision but total flexibility for how you
accomplish it that's what's really
important as an entrepreneur if I look
at my my mission what I'm trying to do
here I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I feel I have the
potential to do it I want to do it
because on a one-on-one level that's
just fulfilling to know that what I do
is meaningful that I have an impact that
I wake up daily and I get to do
something that impacts somebody else's
life you know that that means something
to me seeing your comments come in every
day fills up my soul knowing that I put
work out there and it's being received
Wow and it's having an impact on your
lives that means a lot to me on a big
scale I think entrepreneurs are gonna
solve all the problems of the world
right it's not cup it's not companies
it's not corporations it's not
government it's us we're gonna solve it
and if I can help a billion
entrepreneurs do something greater in
their companies to help solve real
problems that's a major impact I've had
and so having a you know half a percent
impact on your life makes me feel like
I'm having a huge impact on the world
and that's what I set out to do a lot of
you guys see me as a youtuber and I've
said many times I'm not addicted to
YouTube you know I see YouTube as the
best platform right now for someone like
me to spread my message to someone like
you so it's the best path for me on my
mission to achieve my big goal but that
may change and I anticipate that it will
change YouTube will not be the big
player probably in 10 years so what's
the thing that's gonna come along that
will replace YouTube that I have to jump
in on because I'm gonna hit my goal I
want to have that impact right and so
even the types of video so that's like
on a macro of the main strategy right
the main strategy is YouTube and book
and website and that will change in the
future but even the micro strategy
within YouTube okay so u2 is one of the
main strategies micro strategy believe
life series top 10 series meant to me
series and espresso series 7 way series
right those are constantly in flux
what's working what's having an impact
what's helping us achieve our mission
which ones are herded in channel or just
stagnating that we know that we need to
eliminate and bring something else in
right so not being so attached to say
this is a series that even if it doesn't
work I still have to do it this is the
only series that's gonna work if I was
like that then we wouldn't be having the
impact that we have right now it doesn't
help me further my mission and so I
think too often entrepreneurs who start
businesses are not stubborn enough about
where they want to go about the mission
vision and they end up quitting too soon
and they're too stubborn about how they
go and execute their playing and they're
not open enough to other feedback to say
hey I want to help you get that mission
to happen here's another way to be able
to go out and do it so the question
today today is I'm curious what is
something that you've had to change
about your plan since getting started
you went out with this plan and you
realize that something didn't work and
you had to make an adjustment that then
ended up working for you what was that
change what changing your plan that
little tweak that you made how did it
work I'd love to hear from you down in
the comments below and I think it could
help the other entrepreneurs watching as
well and if you leave a comment within
the first couple hours is Vida going
live you have a chance when one of our
two daily prizes I also want to give a
quick shout out to Mike Lamott from
chart your trade comm Mike thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word really really means a lot
to me man and I hope you enjoyed the
read thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso
[Music]
I what my my assistants got a great
thing now in this once in every four
months somebody sends an email saying
I've got a huge startup that I want you
to invest in but you've got to sign this
NDA right which literally every time
gets an email back that says Q right and
and the reason is I'm a humongous
believer that ideas are [ __ ] and that
executions the game right we've all got
ideas
everybody's got ideas do you any ideas
we all have here we can probably sit
here for the next two hours draw them
all out record them and predict the next
78 great startups over the next nine
years and so I think the thing that is
another theme in entrepreneurship is
there is way too much fodder brought to
the idea Hoover was magic cab three
years earlier
uber is not an idea who ever existed
it's called magic cab but the guys that
execute it sucked so they lost so I
think you know if there's any level of
romance left in this room about your
idea I'd like to suffocate it because I
think the actual situation is what you
actually do with it I mean the reality
is reading a book or going to a
conference or having a great
conversation where you get this golden
information that's all fantastic but
what makes mastery is execution on the
ideas not the ideas and so no idea works
unless you're willing to roll up your
sleeves do the practice invest the time
put in the effort do the work I think
we've all observed a lot of people who
they love reading the books they love
showing up at the courses they do all
the online training and nothing ever
changes and they say well you know I
don't know why it doesn't change why my
life doesn't change why my thinking
doesn't change why my performance
doesn't change why my relationships
don't change well it's because ideas
don't work if you don't execute on them
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit one thing that makes them great is
their hunger
to practice one thing that makes them
great is they are willing to sacrifice I
mean yes they're passionate but did you
know the root of the word passion is
suffering you've got to be willing to
suffer for your vision you've got to be
willing to suffer to reach BIW best in
world you've got to be willing to suffer
the ridicule and laughter of your
critics and your cynics to get to a
place called world class I mean not a
lot of people know that you are
fantastic direct response marketer with
your mail-order business dollar into to
concept well you know we all pay taxes
and we all hate the idea that you're
losing that money but there's a
difference between hating that you lose
their money in hating to pay taxes I
love paying taxes if it is the fairmount
and if it is used wisely I think we all
have to contribute it because that's how
he said of social programs that's how
you build infrastructure that's how you
have a military and all of this kind of
thing so that's great but that always
had the belief that the money that
they're paying taxes I want to make up
through wise investments so this is why
I got into real estate right away in the
70s and I started buying raw land and
developing that I started buying
apartment buildings and you know just
think about it I mean it would be in the
Arab in 1974 I bought my first apartment
building and we bought it for two
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
that's it was then a lot of money yeah
and I put only down like maybe thirty
five thirty seven thousand dollars but
within two years the apartment building
was worth instead of two hundred fifteen
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and assorted so imagine now how much
gain there was yeah right I mean so we
made hundreds of percent of my initial
investment so that's what I'm talking
about so it is it takes you know
thoughts and ideas can make much more
money than actual physical labor and
physical labor is always part of the
action
because I always say you got to work
your ass off in the middle of what you
do because now you have a great idea but
then you still have to implement it and
if the hassle if to go to the bank at
the financial statement to this and that
and they raise money sometimes and you
couldn't look at a thousand apartment
buildings to find the right one and all
this kind of things so you still have to
work but normally if it's just physical
labor you can never make the money then
you can make when you have ideas so this
is why it's important that we tell
people I say the secret is is there's
certain times don't think like when you
get up in the morning don't think just
roll out of bed go any lifecycle or go
on a passing it right or go to the gym
work out you know that's what you have
to do and then read something and learn
something so don't even think about it
but there's other times where you have
to really think and you really have to
get creative and have a clear vision of
where you want to go and what you want
to do and that's what I always had and
that's what I always believed and always
believed in making money so that then
you can do something with that you
invest in it notice eventually you
create a family you give some of the
kids and all that stuff but also for
charity look I have the dish what's lega
institute that you will see yeah so we
have to raise money all the time that
make money do to do to pay for tetanus
and the support that 50 our 20 the
environmental organization well any
organization any idea is great but if
you don't lift the money you can
implement anything and so this is why it
is important that it is an environmental
organization or if it is my after-school
programs to the nationwide where we
raise millions and millions of dollars
every year or if it is just you know
living in a great a great mansion or
driving a nice Bentley in the Bugatti
you know this is the kind of things it
takes money to do this kind of stuff so
therefore I believe in making $1 in the
two and having a good time
way to pay my taxes Hamas's Arnold I say
we have bad news here you video fifty
million dollars and taxes
I say Wow yes then little bit misses
that means you must have made a lot of
money in you have to pay that much money
in taxes miss it yeah that's the way
looking at it and said it's the way I
look at it